[Music]
hey really quickly glad to be with you I
uh apologize for the late start today
but we actually have quite a few mug
Club exclusives uh mug Club undercover
today we have some updates on PornHub
and them facing the music as well as uh
we had some people on the ground
yesterday at the uh state capital I
guess we're not going with Insurrection
uh but exclusive footage here today that
has not been aired anywhere else so if
you want to send your tips or be a part
of the mug Club Army undercover we do
rely on you as well as our experts here
you can go to uh well you can send an
email to lwc tips protonmail.com that's
lwc tips protonmail.com and keep in mind
that um our folks here who specialize in
this they will protect your privacy
they'll even go to jail um to protect
your privacy which by the way um uh
Gerald I should probably let you know
that you're you're going to jail so uh
enjoy the show we have a lot of that
coming up
Mr Diplo Pao doctor who reads at a fifth
grade level dealo is that Sicilian no
it's not Sicilian it's Italian
interesting Mr depalo I would like to
conduct today for you a raw Shack Test
please tell me what you see when you
look at this Photograph that's a vagina
interesting what do you see when you
look at this Photograph that's the same
vagina interesting I would like to try
for my one final test
examining this Photograph that's the
same vagina what are we doing here Mr
doollo it is my formal diagnosis that
you are in fact obsessed with vaginas
I'm obsessed you're the one showing me
pictures of your wife's box the jokes on
you are not married this is a picture of
a box from a hobo who I found in East
Germany she was forced to sell her body
to feed her family she now lives in the
gutter along with some crabs and silt
and you said she sold her box to mean
her vagina or the cardboard box Mr
depalo I don't know why you ask me
questions to which you already know the
answer is this a defense mechanism you
find yourself using frequently
absolutely it's worked out well I made
almost $1,800 dur comedy lash and he saw
this as a measure for Success the
$1,800 for $1,800 times he had sold a
portion of his soul which he will never
yield back did I say that out loud yes
you did Doctor remember none of this is
possible without you join the fight and
sign up for mug club today at ler.com
mugclub for $89 annually join the fight
at lc.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today I
[Music]
know spe
okay before I get to anything else I
screwed up in the cold open admonish me
Tool Man admonish Captain Morgan
informed me I I said state capital said
state capital it's just you know it's
the you know one in d i underplayed the
severity you did this be this is going
to be a fun
program
that's okay we had it scheduled in
advance so we have a lot to get to today
I told you we have a lot of exclusive uh
content today mug Club undercover um as
well as ardan young returning regarding
her story as it relates to uh PornHub
yeah uh and now not only the underage uh
pornography that's been presented there
um but them knowing about it and
specifically pedaling it for profit to
their quote unquote largest whales so
this is something where she's really
putting herself in the line of fire we
appreciate the work that they're doing
and then we also had some people on the
ground yesterday at the cap
the capital the capital some people call
them insurrectionists some people call
them protesters I call them
insurrectionists okay so we're going to
do a then and now comparing the January
6 protesters line by line versus uh what
happened yesterday because I know some
people have been making false
equivalencies this isn't a whataboutism
this is disabusing you of the notion
that one is a protest whereas one was uh
inherently a violent Riot we also have a
Victoria Secret then and now mhm that's
an important one turns out that uh the
wokeism didn't make any money for
Victoria Secret I don't know who and we
also have of course Biden's insane
Israel uh comments which will bring us
to a 7 chin was not Photoshopped it
wasn't I thought it was I thought it was
as well that was all right how are you
sir I'm doing well better than you
you're your your neck is still hurting
actually is better now a little bit
because I have the The cwe Distillery
thing it does it does work but it's you
know I can't feel my right
arm so at some point you see me oh God
oh God it's happening
I don't know why you would need to throw
it over either way but you know leave
it how how you even gripping it yeah
that's
fair it's a dramatization no I have the
zingers going down and uh when you hear
this in third chair that means a my my
computer's being shitty
I'm
like could use without the go without
the potty mouth there Yakuza funniest
man alive you can watch him here on mug
club and also the free show every day
wherever you can get your podcast Apple
Spotify Instagram you all of that uh
Nick doollo how are you sir I'm
tremendous how are you Stephen how's the
neck and yeah I already asked that Nick
where were you hey what he wants to he
was he wants to be where were you it's
the softer side of Nick don't turn him
don't scare him he'll stick his head
back undergr exactly crying Gerald yeah
Gerald father of the
cloth father of the cloth what the
hell's that yeah I don't know I was
going to of you pretty redundant you mix
man the cloth and Father of the Bride
reference are
you Steve Martin H all right we're on
our aame yeah it's well look we had to
get the zoom working where we have um we
have our on later so this is why we had
to start we want to make sure whenever
we do something uh that you bring to us
exclusively and work with our team that
we we do we do it justice so it takes a
little bit of extra time also we could
get sued
yes not a joke yeah I get the paperwork
but let me ask you this I do have a
question well you know what I'll just
ask the question questions as we go
along with each topic how about that
first
up H I forgot about this
one here's a girl mhm uh writing a poem
I guess speaking a
poem garbling a PO belching a poem uh
about fatness and this is why Western
Society will cease to exist this is a
poem I wrote called fat girl fat girl
too big fat girl looks sloppy and
unpolished fat girl is the punchline of
your joke but one day getting rid of
conjunctions fat girl starts speaking a
little louder stops apologizing for
needing
more suit over maybe not choose the seat
directly next to her her voice is deep
and Loud fat girl not her fault may not
be pretty to you but they fil beautiful
and to about 25 other men in her DM fat
girl is proud of her fat every pound a
witness a testimony Witnesses just how
strong she truly is really F girl is me
well than spoil spoiler alert thanks for
connecting the
[Music]
dots going to make them at some point
today okay and by the way some people
complain like you know you say you're
not going to self-censor but then you
have the YouTube dump button what do you
want come on you guys it's the best we
can do we we are on Rumble we're
suspended all the time by the way the
YouTube dump button I mean it's still
not a foolproof plan it's not we get
suspended almost
always it doesn't
work all right it's start your own show
yeah well we're trying to solve the
problem look I'd love to hear you
comment well genuinely we're trying to
solve the problem of being on the
platform
where people who have not been reached
who need to hear uh the truth out there
that's why we make all the references
available we want to be there but we're
not going to do it at the cost of Truth
our best solution is the YouTube dump
button at this point in time but I am
open to suggestions which we will most
likely reject so don't take it
personally honesty here is uh for and
we'll only take suggestions if you're a
member of mug Club lc.com mug Club there
you go and by the way if this show is
too much for you probably won't be a big
fan of Nick at 5:00 p.m. I'll tell you
it's a more tame than You' think you
um oh I forgot again YouTube
damn it I I'll get this all right don't
worry it's not as bad as what we're
about to watch next so during his Israel
trip look just Biden he said some very
insane things including funding uh Hamas
but here you go
look look a bunny look at his chin
heting that Hamas deliberately did it
either old thing know how sh string is
highly improbable that Israel did that
that's just behind are there Israelis um
operating within the rules of war that
you talked about last week being so
important good talking to you thank you
sir wow what did he say and he also I
believe do we have the clip of him
saying he's sending $100 million to uh
Palestine I he tweeted it out anyways
that $100 million is being given to to
promise uh yeah the Palestinian
government so uh do we make that out to
cash or Rockets
I think it's the DJ Corporation deice
yes
yes hey please please just make sure
guys you don't use this 100 million for
anything other than humanitarian Aid
okay yes got it it's just obvious from
looking at the area that they're not
spending it on Bridges and Roads and
tunnels exactly you know what I mean
it's pretty obvious the Israelis have
cut off our water why don't you have do
your own watering and just to be clear
we're going to do a segment on that next
week people are saying oh no Israel has
blocked the Palestinian people's
government from from accessing any water
that's not true they're uh they could
triple their capacity entirely paid for
by the International Community just to
be clear that's everything from new
drilling sites that have already they
already have permits for them it's like
us with oil they just don't use
them is it desalinization is it
desalination or desalinization iation
desalinization plants which by the way
are very expensive they could increase
their capacity they've chosen instead to
Tunnel into two areas of Israel and kill
them um and uh you know danan gets
expensive is all I'm saying so we know
that M exploits Aid right we can give
you a few examples where they ceased
hundreds of pounds of un Aid by the way
including food and blankets and then
they uh turned EU funded water pipes
into homemade Rockets they literally
took the pipes and turned them into
rockets and then they of course stole
some more charitable funding uh to
construct military bases so and they
bought a ton of Fender guitars that was
surprising Yes actually no they went
they went off BR they bought Squire
Strat suck it's not even a offender ah
oh we have the $100 million clip if you
I bet you the the Jews have Gibsons am I
right they all have Gibsons they do
right let's grab the cliff yeah
look look it's my thumb and I'm not
suggesting that Hamas deliberately did
it either that's the same it's that old
thing got to Le how to Sho it's highly
prob that Israel did that Mr President
is are the Israelis um operating within
the rules of war that you talked about
last week being so important I have to
take a off thank you sir appr today
I'm also announcing energ $100 million
in new US funding for humanitarian
assistance in both Gaza and the West
Bank oh what 100 million I wonder what
they could do with that h100 million
yeah and to be fair he did seem very
distraught um and he wants to draw
attention away from you know the fact
that his son Hunter uh likely will end
up in prison which since today is a
heavy Day brings us to this week 7 plus
[Music]
one you forgot the I'm in the
chamber this week is 7even plus one
things Hunter Biden is doing to prepare
for
prison plus one uh let's start off with
uh Gerald a number seven I wondered
learning to craft a fine prison toilet
wine there's some ala so you would be
the judge of that gen yeah 7 plus1
Things Hunter Biden is doing to prepare
for Prison number six getting fitted for
a custom ass
balloon they make those custom
number five things that Hunter B is
doing to prepare for prison seems right
up Nick's alley number five up my alley
gross uh pre scheduling conjugal visits
with his dead brother's widow yum yum
ouch
ouch that's not tasteful in the day of
Natalie
Holloway is it that day again I don't
know I saw it in the news wh back I'm
still I'm still not over Natalie
Wood number four 7 plus1 Things Hunter
Biden is doing to prepare for prison uh
ensuring the commissary has has an
acceptable spectrum of smokable cheese
that's a yeah he does you have that's a
great joke because on a couple levels
but go
ahead thanks for the critique noque is
that a critique it's a number three s
plus one thinks h b is do to prepare for
prison uh Nick carefully uh learning his
prison's septic floor plan so he can uh
tunnel his way to
the nearest cracked in
I you know it would been nice if
somebody gave these to me before
the show but that's a good joke on
several levels Nick
um number two think H B is doing to
prepare for prison and this is this is
something that a lot of he's employing
the key strategy of finding the biggest
and toughest inmate in his cell block so
that he can get raped by him
[Laughter]
first so many layers number one just
because I want to make Gerald
uncomfortable number one is taking
lessons from Ashley on group showering
well look that's Ashley Biden yes that's
the finishing school wow that's oh that
one's missing and then the uh 7 plus one
this is the plus one things that Hunter
Biden is currently doing to prepare for
his prison stint knitting scarves for
the Aryan Brotherhood yeah that's a well
come on hey look they get cold too it's
wrong to hate but you look good doing it
that's this week 7 plus
[Music]
one you forgot the I'm in the chamber
I'm sorry Nick I can never tell if it's
a compliment or if it's just take it and
move on oh my goodness it was a
compliment I think I don't know either
so this brings us to uh this is a more
of a cultural uh installment
uh Victoria Secret remember them yeah so
they uh just announced that they will be
going back to their roots and focusing
on quote sexiness again good so this is
the latest installment you know people
say go woke go broke but look I would
certainly think that uh diversity is not
the primary
metric uh involved with making lingerie
attractive or sexy it just seem like
this would be self-explanatory but
according to a recent CNN report
Executives spoke with some people at CNN
because they think it's still a network
uh the prime objective was to improve
profitability and uh cross back over the
7 billion in annual sales because they
did not meet their Benchmark and sales
were down you don't
say they had favorable reviews as they
switched to the woke you know the fat
models and the trans models uh online
critics but it didn't translate into
actual sales is what they do uh you mean
folks didn't find chicks wearing French
cut underwear whose asses look like a
relief map of the Himalayas they didn't
find that attract I
don't are you sucking my
ass hey can we move this this is the
stupidest thing
I who put this fraking Hamas bomb box
the mute buttons keep it's right where
there's no a white man's problem there's
no place to put the cop it's a
it's a mute button if you hit the switch
it mutes you other than hell hello hello
hello yeah yeah it's doing nothing no
there you go fake there's jewelry in it
for Christ sake he's so angry he's so
angry the practical joke doesn't
[Laughter]
work only I could I the weight of my
hand what was that what is that it
flicks the button back you you hit the
switch and it just opens up and turns
the switch engers I've ever met I think
we had a I can't even look we had a
South Korean could be in the worst
anyway you can move it it doesn't matter
is it stuck is it glued to the table
maybe oh God yes it's like again an idea
oh wow I just thought wow that was meant
to be like a temporary temporary joke
and it's a I guess it's a fixture now
well hit the like button if you're ready
to have hot
models back to Victoria's Secret yes
like for some reason this is this is the
issue right the right will often just
fight the cultural they say culture wars
but everything is is is uh Downstream or
Upstream depending on how you express it
from culture uh they do it when it's too
late the left says hey you know what we
need we need uh Buzz Lightyear kissing a
or whatever we need a lesbian kiss hey
you know what we need trans children in
our shows Netflix says we need cuties
they say hey you know what Victoria
Secret we need to have um you know
women's lingerie models be men and then
it just becomes reactive now the good
news is the Bots work and the boycots
work but they are they really are
playing 11d chess uh we just happen to
be lucky to see this
backfire which brings us to then and
[Music]
now I don't know if there's like an
update of software to everything in our
studio last night yeah but nothing is
working properly it's not you deserve
better but you know what we
can't not
today tricaster just decid to reboot all
right so this gives us a contrast where
you can sometimes it helps to actually
have visual aids uh so this let's go
back to then right back then Victoria
Secret originally and then we'll go to
the now and and they're going to switch
now so the future is probably going to
look more like the then but back then
Heidi
[Music]
Clum ah oh my God
now Megan
rapo again the fact that I feel
comfortable in it pieces are sort of
interchangeable I can wear them dressed
up dressed down but ultimately even if
you're just wearing them on their own in
the way that we look the muscl the scars
of this or that gross what do you have
to say yes uh salesperson I would like
to pay Victoria's Secret prices but with
Fruit of the Loom style yeah I always
wanted to Dennis
Larry
put a helmet
on get in there I'd rather go with just
basic hannes and and find Michael Jordan
in beding oh honest to God man so let's
go back to then back then they had
Adriana Lima Victoria's Secret
right
oh she's a
[Music]
b
what were they thinking no offense my
dad's ass would look good in that
outfit so with Natalie Woods today's
Natalie Wood brings us to now needs more
Ali take
[Music]
Cutler call out culture when someone
does something that we don't like we
call them out and we say canel you're
done yeah she say like it's a good thing
okay let's go back to to then Victoria
Secret right they had uh they had
Candace Swain
[Music]
pole it's like they don't know their
audience at all which brings us to
[Music]
now
p
you oh it's an unrealistic body standard
that's I think far more achievable for
most women out there than it is for men
to go watch Mr Olympia go see Mr Olympia
male models or you look at Men's Health
we have to have veins in our ABS you
don't have to pick between being a model
or living past
40 it requires obscene amounts of
anabolic steroids diuretics cigarettes
and
cocaine you just need to not eat for a
little while I like the way they raise
these it's it's like Veil they put them
in a
pen just milk and uh Darkness so the
muscles don't develop then they have
it's like a Wu that's right W every time
he tells me about the best steak he's
ever had here in Texas a Wu steak oh my
God help so now Victoria's going back
they're going back they're saying we're
going to go back to sexy du tape on the
crutch they're saying yeah we think that
we think we think that women want this
you know let's split the difference so
the tides are turning hence the beach
whes uh but how did we get
[Music]
here Beauty can't be measured beauty is
fluid
everchanging it comes in all forms and
from all walks of
life Beauty has many faces
colors and most of all beauty comes from
within everyone is
beautiful everyone is
sexy hover around so separately oh I
think you're going to
hell I'll be glad to go in when when
Nick is laughing because he thinks it's
mean it makes me question my creative
choices it's just it's not your choices
it's the how did we get to this point
where a woman has flippers and
she I mean she can't even didd herself
with her it's like Ste well
stepen Hawking had to be smart he wasn't
just a model it's true true that's the
thing now it's just no no you're also
beautiful how about the woman he blew
off Stephen how does she feel
yeah it's not you it's
me and he does a couple
donuts don't worry it happens to lots of
girls I think we should just be
Friends by I don't need another black
hole
of but thank you for helping me with my
Milky
Way shut
up where do you get this footage it's so
I don't know how much of that was real
now oh I think it all was you never know
you can't tell fact from fiction anymore
we are at that point when when when you
have when you have a trans man modeling
for Victoria's Secret I know well that's
what I mean I believe it's real cuz you
do have a trans we know that's Prett
okay it's not a big leap for a girl with
flippers put put on a bikini no
a you know Butchy lesbian who's trying
to look
ugly fine it's not a big and then
complaining about pay it's like you're
being paid to be the most unattractive
underwear model ever yes something
doesn't add up a 140 hitter you de sign
for $60 million a year yeah exactly and
complains all right you suck die so this
brings us to the pro Kidd and look I
have a question for you um do you see
the differences before we get into it
spoiler alert the uh Pro Palestine
demonstrations there yesterday at the
capital versus January 6th and I know a
lot of people have tried to kind of
compare contrast the two but we wanted
to do so in in a way that was more
quantifiable concrete for you and we
make the references available at lc.com
so we do have some exclusive footage
today as well that has never been seen
before uh which would remove all doubt
as to it being a quote unquote planned
Insurrection how do I know because I say
so you yes it's in their it's in their
own words and you can all take part by
sending in your tips to our tip line LC
tips protonmail.com so first let's just
kind of give you a little bit of a recap
yesterday a group of these pramas not
jobs and let's be clear these people are
pramas pramas they took over the capital
in DC
[Music]
[Applause]
that doesn't look like they're being
invited seems quite unreal by the way
they have signs up there we've talked
about this they have signs saying
ceasefire now see let me be really clear
when people talk about racist dog
whistles right if you say socialist what
you really meant to say was the n-word
with Obama that's what they'll tell you
right if you if you say oh trans male
what you're actually doing is you're
you're calling for it's coded language
to dog whistle for genocide against
trans people this is not a dog whistle
this is a giant blaring siren anyone who
calls for a ceasefire after people have
been raped and murdered sounds nice you
are supporting
[Music]
terrorism soon be over
priest finish
it
[Music]
hey ceasefire ceasefire everyone calm
down hey ceasefire calm down
guys we have on the payroll so this
whole thing was this protest was
organized by Jewish voice Jewish voices
for peace no or it's One Singular Jewish
voice for peace I guess is the
organization one of them the ADL pretty
leftist organization defines them as an
anti-zionist leftist
group and it took place here's the thing
there are a lot of parallels between um
what we saw January 6 except you know
these people actually had more horrible
intentions off the bat um they were you
would say instigated by right they tried
to say that Donald Trump instigated what
happened January 6 we'll get to that
clip because that clip is always
important to run to make your voices
heard peacefully and patriotically uh
let's compare that to how this started
it was spurred on by Rashida clay or at
least they went into the capital stormed
the capital shortly after she addressed
the crowd right there
outside the capital so a lot of people
don't realize that they thought some
people online thought that Rashida CL
was speaking to some small rally in
Dearborn no this this this this is the
context so now when you see her words I
think those words matter and again
comment below if you think this
Insurrection is worse than Pearl Harbor
and 911 combined that's what I think
it's
9112 so let's go uh to then and now do
we have the clip from rashita Tay back
we have it we have it down a little bit
further because it kind of specifically
ju opposed okay let's do that so let's
go back to then before we go to rashita
flip because when you take it in context
or comments are a little bit I would say
shocking in comparison you were told
that Donald Trump incited Violence
January 6th okay here is Donald Trump
back then telling protesters to make
their voices peacefully heard he used
those words I know that everyone here
will soon be marching over to the capol
building to peacefully and patriotically
make your voices heard they never show
you that they don't they never show and
patriotically weird and right after that
immediately ABC news said this is what
Trump told supporters before many
stormed to the capital the president
incited those who attended his rally to
March to the capital and we that's
that's the most mild one we could find
he didn't even by because then they said
they called him to storm it violently I
know but he actually is just he's like I
hear this is what you're doing he didn't
say go do it anyway they're stupid but
that's always what he does I know in
other words I wouldn't put he didn't do
it but I wouldn't put it past him say
and and people tell me that you have a
shaman who's going to go in the house
going to take a selfie in NY Pelosi's
desk and take a take a fantastic dump at
NY Pelosi's desk I would never do that
what they tell me go Shaman so they say
they say it no one says that people say
it
I heard it once people say it in a
subway car what people so that brings us
to now
t uh the only representative with a
ticking pants suit making veiled threats
the capital to Biden I want him to know
as a Palestinian American is also
somebody of Muslim faith I'm not going
to forget this and I think a lot of
people are not going to forget this and
it's not it's not it's not it's not a
threat it isn't they they think we're
joking now see by itself it's not a
threat but oh so not she's it's
basically saying it's a promise yes it's
not a threat they think we're joking
well hold on a second is it right is it
are you so you're not joking Mak it a
threat so it's not a joke it's not a
threat oh that's a
claim that's a promise there you go I
think it's her outfit that made us think
she was joking yeah it was two sizes
true so t uh by the way this is being
covered by ABC News so we wanted to have
a direct apples apples parison ABC News
covered it as T refuses to apologize for
blaming Israel for Gaza Hospital blast
attacks Biden the backlash to T's
remarks shows divides within the
Democratic party oh that's it that's
that's the most important thing there
yeah no link to the protesters uh
regarding her rhetoric which yeah how
about adding the word falsely yes uh R
to won't back off our comments falsely
attributing the Gaza Hospital explosion
to Israel it could just read Rashid T
won't admit the truth that there you go
that's even that's a shorter headline
and it's not even a div in the Democrat
Party just with with Biden making his
false statement it appears a divide but
behind closed doors you're right right
with it when people say oh the the left
Fringe that's the entire who is in the
DNC today who you would not consider
left Fringe right they say oh the right
goes left and the we've done a whole
segment on this the left has been
moderate and the right has gone too far
right hold on a second hold on a second
so when you have the president saying uh
I think it's evil for you to not affirm
your six-year-old's gender right how is
that not Fringe believing that's as
Fringe as you get and this is in the
Oval Office by the way also the Vice
President also the speaker of the house
when Nancy Pelosi was in that role every
single person if a if plane after plane
were to go down and we were to go
through the line of success every single
person in that line of succession
would be someone who supports children
transitioning uh as well as you know a
marginal tax rate while we're talking
economics of likely 80% the point is
there is no nonf fringe DNC you might
have people who vote Democrat and
they're not French there is no one in
the head of the party this is what they
actually believe now let's let's bring
this to speaking of the people let's go
to how the protesters actually conducted
themselves yeah in compar because I
think that's important so let's go back
to then January 6th now you weren't
shown this on media and when we actually
ran these clips we were suspended from
YouTube that's why we do this on Rumble
we showed it the next day we were on air
the next day that the majority of these
protesters not only did they respect the
people's house they were invited
[Music]
in
p
look look at that it makes me so mad
when I go back and watch that so they
were invited in by uh Capital Poli not
everyone but a good portion of them and
then you had Representatives fleeing
going where's the
camera and then the people walk in and
follow the ropes just if you ever
wondered how dishonest your government
how dishonest the media is right there
QQ and on Shaman that man did Serious
time in jail years think about that he's
on camera being invited in and being
entirely peaceful and Al he's also
saying let's keep it peaceful so let's
compare that to now as opposed to being
invited in it was a a stage sit in which
is always silly I mean it's a good
protest for lazy people yeah don't have
to actually do anything after they
blocked traffic around the capital
complex and they forced their way in
that's
now is he trying to commit suicide yeah
I said let him go officer yeah yeah let
nature take its
[Applause]
course fire now
fire
[Applause]
fire and and by the way as it always is
they left tons of pro Palestinian
graffiti remember when the Tea Party
when they would have these tea parties
say oh it must be racist organizations
where they would actually be walking
around with Pokey sticks cleaning up
trash and the media said they're trying
to stab black guys with poke sticks
meanwhile in Ducati Park Occupy Wall
Street you may forget that people they
they they made it a common practice to
take a steaming on cop
cars which is Impractical and and throw
dirty needles into people's tents as
they slept this is the way the left
operates it's always graffiti it's
always violent it's always disruptive
and then they blame the right of doing
exactly what it is that they do now
let's contrast the treatment that we saw
of uh January 6 the the people who were
protesting or the people who were
arrested I guess at this point versus
what we just saw yesterday let's go back
to then over 1100 protesters were hit
with federal charges federal charges the
proud boys guy Enrique toio who as far
as we know they didn't even accuse him
of violence 22 years in prison at least
six people were sentenced to at least 12
years in prison wow you have people
who've distributed child pornography
which we'll get to with PornHub in a
second who do less time yeah and that
brings us to now by the way which is um
a mug Club exclusive we have some more
footage that was on the ground uh are we
are we hitting the Stinger here all
right M Club
undercover so there were some people
Nick just to be fair who were taken to
jail so that's fun
[Laughter]
a than you Bob on a charter they're
taking there on on this on a new charter
bus and uh the thing is they were let
out you know 23 years 12 years it's a
little more severe than being let out
with a $50 bail what in tree with kid
gloves here this is exclusive here they
are talking about
[Music]
[Applause]
it that's a nice then I took to New York
the other
week probably USB charging ports in
there you know you want any food
anything great okay so we have like
fruit Gator chips candies was it cold in
there it's pretty cold I mean it's not
like cold cold but I said
no you really well you were on the side
with people it's at least yeah are you
at a are you at a store or they already
purchased hey how do I 50 means
bail yeah um I think we were having
people text fire hey it's the next
Victoria Secret
Superstar they were giving him fruit and
drinks and treating him really nicely
and they got $50 bail you mean they
weren't kind of kept in a holding sale
that was dark and damp think you me sale
loud sale you said sale itical theme in
my head
you for reasons that we won't get into
today no no didn't mind me let's before
we get to the idea of it being an
interaction at the very least almost all
of these protesters it seems knew that
they were doing something illegal and
that they would get arrested they were
planning again this is exclusive on
getting
arrested it was straight forward as
aded were you on being ared yes and
I I know I'm not even look I'm not even
a white privileged guy but that's what
it looks
like a jail support form were you
planning on getting arrested yeah course
I filled out the form I'm a white girl
though H they'll let me go I don't know
she could be 11/16th Cherokee I don't
care now was it an Insurrection that
term has been thrown around so
flippantly that it's lost all meaning so
now I'll use it uh because the
protesters themselves at the very least
allude to it being an Insurrection if
not just saying
it yeah
they another Insurrection and this
time oh my
god well hold on a second I don't want
to misquote and again this is exclusive
so you will say that we've taken this
out of context you can go and watch
these clips longer versions you can
follow me on X Twitter go watch them
there I know we'll have them on on mug
Club I believe as well but X is the best
place for raw footage was it in
Insurrection filthy hippie there at the
capital please answer one more
time yeah they
said
another oh my
God they know it's consequence for
another but this time no one got no one
had any
consequences jeez so look this is we're
incredibly none of this happens without
you without you joining at lc.com club
and sending in your tip
now don't expect the media to cover this
so I ask that you go out and make sure
that people see this footage whether
it's on X Facebook Instagram we'll make
it available there along with the
exclusive that we have coming up
regarding the uh the PornHub story yeah
they say it's an Insurrection they
showed up they planned to be arrested
some of them were but they were released
$50 boom scotf free don't expect the
media to cover it just like you can
expect them to cover any conservative
protest and by the way it wasn't just
January 6 they did it with the Tea Party
yeah they did it with every single right
they did it with Donald Trump rallies
right the only difference is that some
individuals at January 6th screwed up
that's it but not all of them not all of
them yeah they broke a window and
knocked over some white out yes exactly
sorry my neck is having a feeling ill
headache fever have a chill is this what
is going on CB Distillery is this yeah I
oh yeah well I do need to give it just
know you know what leave it Josh that's
go just I don't need you to treat me
good to see you again Nick yeah that's
disgusting
he was going to apply it for I'm not I'm
not lying by the way my neck is because
of this it doesn't fix the nerve uh
problem the nerves fall on your
neck uh they are sponsor to the show and
by the way I have used this for a very
long I've used their oral CBD stuff for
a very long time use it at night and it
helps but uh this thing has been a
miracle um you can go to CB
distillery.com use the promo code
Crowder for 20% off uh and they have all
of the science there does it helps with
pain helps with sleep and the best part
about CB distiller is they have their
stuff is lab tested yeah yeah so you can
go there see their certificate of
analysis you know that you are getting
exactly what it is that they tell you
they are selling and they have the balls
to sponsor this show you use some yeah
yeah absolutely and it's not something
like gas station selling you know CBD
products available here also next to the
stamps and postcards it's like okay yeah
7 you get stamped at a gas you can yeah
if you want you can get bombs at a gas
station if it's a 7-Eleven true I don't
know what it's good products I I
actually talk to their guys and the
scientists like they literally like hey
we'll jump on the phone we'll tell you
exactly what you need it's not you don't
always need every single thing that they
offer so go on and look this a topical
thing and by the way you can use your
stuff you don't get high I know people
out there that's why it's legal across
the United States will it help will it
help with a broken heart depends on rub
it Nick that means I'm write that one
down uh not this one this say men it say
Menthol so that would that would end
badly it' be like raking that was the
joke cool that's the black uh pain yes
yes and the promo C is Crowder again 20%
off at CB Distillery okay we have did
you have anything else you wanted to get
into on the January 6th compared to uh
you know what I was really quickly I
actually was talking with denes Dua
yesterday we'll have his interview on
airing on Monday uh here and he was
talking about on January 6 do you know
what the the proceeding that they
interrupted that that everybody get in
trouble for well I don't have the answer
but I believe you're going to tell me
you would be correct so uh basically
they were interrupting the part where
the Republicans were going to challenge
the votes and send it back to the states
that was not the certification I didn't
know that yeah because that's what
everybody says they tried to stop the
certification no what they actually did
is they made it to where the Republicans
didn't get the chance to even object
they screwed themselves yeah in this
process yep so when you're talking about
comparing January 6 to a violent
Insurrection where you had a handful of
people get out of control which should
be they should face charges right they
they did to what happened yesterday tell
me the difference they interrupted
government proceedings as well they
maybe not proceedings to help themselves
like we accidentally we actually screwed
ourselves and shot ourselves in the foot
by doing it at the same time Republicans
were trying to do it but they kind of
they'll probably claim it as a victory
that $100 million is being given to
Hamas the pales will but it's not it's
definitely not like I I hate that
January 6 got made into what it was I
really do because we didn't fight back
and I blame Adam keninger and we talked
about this andame I blame them both of
those guys but I also blame conservative
I blame conservative media you know
we've talked about in the past big con
because we were out there when people
thought that what Tucker was
broadcasting was new we were going why
is this a story we did it to the tune of
I think three or 4 million of you tuned
in right as it happened and then we did
an entire episode dedicated to it when
they were about to do the hearings for
January 6th they canceled it because of
a hurricane in Florida and so and I will
tell this behind the scenes so many cons
it's just not worth it the Optics the
third rail I'm going well hold on a
second there are people in prison there
are people in prison who've done nothing
illegal or violent just to be clear yeah
but it's just not a fight it's just not
a fight that we want to take on how to
be for the people yeah but but so just
just to be clear too people that
literally all they did was walk into the
capital building I'm not talking about
people who actually were violent I'm not
talking about people who even took a
picture behind Nancy Pelosi's desk I'm
talking about people who literally
walked in with their phone was looking
around taking video even people who said
they were on their reporters essentially
taking video and left charges well when
does being invited in become storming
that's my question is it is it a matter
of different entry point maybe they
didn't invite them in at this entry
point but at this entry point or does it
happen once you invite people in then
you create enough chaos to say that
these people stormed in I bet you that
if we didn't have that footage which by
the way we ran I believe people can go I
believe it was January 7th whatever our
first day back was after that after that
happened um if we didn't have that
footage if you didn't have access to
that footage let's go back to the days
where there were only three networks you
would have never seen that these people
were invited in yeah you would have been
told that they stormed the capital you'd
have no way to back check them that's
also why the big Tech battle is the most
important of our lifetime because they
want to ensure that you cannot post that
content they were invited in a huge
number of them by the way including K on
Shaman who did time yeah he did federal
Time Imagine imagine if you didn't have
Twitter if we didn't have Rumble you
would never know that and I still don't
have the answers to when being invited
in becomes storming by the way the
representative who pulled the fire alarm
to delay a vote but let's just be clear
he's not a well is a but he's not
that stupid to think a fire alarm opens
a door right uh no charges for him
delaying an official proceeding or
anything like that and these people
obviously a number of people have come
out and said hey you've actually kept it
from people being able to do their jobs
in the capital so you're getting in the
way of the government doing the job of
the government so okay no charges really
for these guys nothing he also ruined
his suit with all that blue ink well
that's true no wait that's because he he
shoplifted it
Lids so die packs at Lids I don't know
do they have die packs at Li I think so
there's nothing it where are they going
to put it in the Hat idea they pin it to
the Hat yeah yeah a d pack guys comment
below we'll take it in chat I'm pretty
sure they have Diet packs at Lids right
no I don't know what Lids is they're
little I don't know what Lids is they
have exploding dieap it's like little
bitty pins security thing I think we
should have finigan go and steal a hat
and see what happens all right but he
has to make sure that he keeps the
Hologram sticker on it after he steals
it that's how you that's how they know
that you're frh fresh so let's go back
to uh we have another you know what
let's hit this thing this is another mud
undercover exclusive but really it's in
partnership with uh with ardan young and
the work uh that they've been doing so
they warrant
this and we're going to have Aron here
in just a few just a few minutes so
about a month ago and Nick was here on
that day too we brought to you uh the
story that PornHub was exploiting a
loophole to facilitate what seemed to be
uh like underage pornography here's a
brief recap what's like the worst that
could happen with a loophole like
that I mean do like no like do rapists
use it or of course of course what about
like human traffickers or
something like could they use that l
to do what make
money okay so since that video uh was
published and by the way the videos that
we show you today are going to be
published right now simultaneously on X
and all social platforms so that you can
post the raw files yeah uh pornhub or
their parent company I should say they
rebranded as Alo their parent company
mind geek since this came out since that
video came out so hit the like button by
the way right now if You' like to see
these rats scatter when the light hits
them by the way if you're going to
repost this which I highly encourage you
to do to make sure that this story gets
out if you're going to quote uh post it
make sure that you don't spell out
PornHub make sure you put like an
asteris in there for the r or something
like that because otherwise that word
kind of gets throttled and we don't want
the story to be throttled we want
everybody to see this okay so make sure
you do that good point jald so what you
about say n I'm just thinking if
somebody some girl is trying to
undercover pull one on me yeah question
they'd never get anything out of me
because they're like will you shut up
and eating your grilled cheese 19
questions in
a you the question
Queen enough already Nick's got a built
and that's when it dawned on me that
Nick Depo was a monster I bring you to
Arby's can you bust my balls for it ask
for extra meat give me some
napkins so uh to follow up on that now
today's uh newest undercover video Dylan
rice who is a senior script writer at uh
mindgeek Alo pornhub's parent company so
again this is Pornhub I'll probably say
PornHub going forward because you don't
know them as Alo like if I say Alo you
don't go PornHub Alo you don't know what
see nobody knows what that means so uh
JLo well I mean you know I bet you
there's probably some Revenge
pornography there as well by the way a
lot of this had to do with child
pornography revenge porn rape human
trafficking that was what that previous
story was about and people tried to say
of course you're taking it out of
context it's just one guy well now we
bring you Dylan Rice's senior script
writer over there uh at pornhup okay
number one company in the porn industry
by far he explains in these clips I
think we have four for you uh we have
three okay how PornHub knowingly props
up uh pedophile Centric content okay so
here is the first clip where he
discusses uh what kind of porn ads get
the most clicks and bring in the most
money stay with it so for the ads the
dudes that do the most like conversion
rates are guys that look like 15 even
though they're like 20 years old or like
25 so there's this one guy named like
Jordy and he just looks like a little
kid and they put him in scen so it looks
like this little kid is like having sex
and like oh I want to be that little kid
like if I had a babysitter or something
but a lot of times these Talent the
women will be like I don't want to have
sex with this kid he looks like 15 it's
weird but it makes a lot of money so so
that kind of stuff has an
heal apparently yeah and then you have
female Talent they're like oh my God
that's I want to corrupt that little boy
that's so
hot do you think that kind of stuff like
encourages child predatory behavior I
don't know I feel like with everything
it's got to be a gray
area where it's kind of more complex
than like yes or
no so on the one hand
it has to be an outlet for somebody
right and like maybe it's good enough
that that's the only place they get it
but on the other hand it kind of
normalizes it right so could go either
way no no it only goes one way it's not
could go either way he's talking about
it like he's a you know the cool mom who
lets her kids smoke in the house so at
least they do it under my roof no no no
no no no no not when we're dealing with
with pedophiles it only goes one way
yeah and and by the way to hell you
could absolutely tell that that was the
direction he was going when he said you
know it's kind of like everything
everything's a gray area no everything
is not a gray area yeah if you live your
life thinking that then obviously you
end up writing scripts for you know porn
that features people that look like
they're underage so that you can get
pedophiles to watch it this is this is
college education for you they say they
say very few things are black and white
no no no no there are some great areas
but there are a lot of things that are
black and white yeah child porn bad
child porn is on that list right if not
then what would be prison Cs and these
are the same PE yes these are the same
people by the way Nick who want to make
everything black and white as it deals
with comedy and entertainment right the
cancel culture no that's unacceptable
but with everything you know I don't
know it's kind of black Nuance hold a
second shouldn't Nuance apply to Comedy
shouldn't Nuance apply to creative
content not to crimes right they want
Nuance with bail right in New York they
want Nuance with with burning down
cities and black lives matter they want
absolute complete full-throated
cancelling for comedians that's how how
you know it's not genuine so let's go to
another clip here rice who just said it
could go both ways he admits that the
audience for the so-called gray area uh
as he referred to it um that the the
people who are being served uh these ads
uh miners
Indians sorry I should say native no
Indians other ones
yeah and pedophiles we have this guy his
name is Jimmy Michaels he looks 13 but
they put him in stuff because he looks
like that but what are we going to do
like not shoot him because he looks that
young if you're leaning into it if
you're like you know putting a like a
little hat with a fan on top of him
right like a little stuffed animal then
it's going to be like hey it's
questionable but if you're just dressing
him like a normal person you can get
over
there that's
true who do you think the audience is on
like videos where the actor looks
13 I think it's a lot of like young
teens like boys that imagine themselves
in thatal and
like I think it's a lot of
uh uh how do I say this it's a lot of
Indians okay our our largest market is
India one of them it's us and then
India yeah it's it's crazy they're like
36% and a lot of them see like the
little ads and they immediately just
think like oh American woman young boy
and they want to be that boy like they
don't really have the same
perspective of like age differences as
we do here cuz like they have like
arranged marriage and stuff like that
I'll show you Jimmy Michaels that's him
right
exactly I would feel wrong watching that
that's a lot of people will not shoot
with him because of that his DS do well
cuz he looks do you think that draws
like
pedophiles but it's weird though because
it's not I think it draws predatory
women because there are a lot of older
women that like I want someone young and
pure that that I can
corrupt still a copile right yes yes yes
S I mean yeah yes and then it's also I
think it's um P ability men who like
seeing young boys two things he looks
like Dennis NRI had sex with a
terrorist and number two I don't this is
why not all cultures are created equal
yeah they're not all created equ even if
what he is saying is true and I'm
willing to bet there's probably some
truth to it guess what that's an
inferior culture we don't allow child
pornography by the way they don't allow
child pornography in India either arrang
marriages certainly you might have
people who are younger when they get
married they're more familiar with the
concept of marriage I'll I'll grant you
that don't believe child porn the way
you do it with a Molly culen understudy
is legal in India and if it were legal
somewhere well guess what some tribes
some tribes allow cannibalism usually in
the in the
Andes but with Pilots but you you you
used to have a bit on this too on to To
Catch a Predator I know that was one of
your your favorite shows a good portion
of them to be fair were Indians well
isn't isn't it funny and and what what
country has the worst problem right now
with girls being gang raped on buses by
young men
India wow okay so let's let's go down
his let's follow his blog I read about
it all the time on the Internet it's
it's outrageous what's going on so why
would you want to serve that demographic
let's go this is the issue right when
people say it's just business no and
that's why we say what we do here at mug
Club it is a business we're not a 501c3
we have a 501c4 but it's not just
business it can't be just business
because that's when you make those kinds
of compromises hey how about you say no
no that's a crappy culture if what your
your premise is true if they allow child
pornography okay we don't serve that we
won't do it you'll have governments by
the way who want to ban
Rumble because they allow you to discuss
Co or because they didn't even ban
Russell Brand just to be clear said no
we're not going to B the knee to them
hey how about your job PornHub yeah no
don't even if it's not kitty porn but
it's meant to look like kitty porn the
answer is no the answer is absolutely no
I just want you to think about the level
of evil in one of the comments that he
said there and he kind of brushed past
it with the women he said you've got a
lot of older women that want that pure
innocence and they want to corrupt that
imagine being the person is like you see
this pure innocence we love our our
children's innocence right we love the
Purity that they have they haven't dealt
with all the difficult things in life
that we've dealt with and all the trials
and tribulations that we've gone through
and there's something that is so
protectable about that that we
absolutely want to kill anyone who tries
to destroy that this is what these
people and it's not just women it's men
too they get off on taking that away
from people who are underage they get
off on the idea of corrupting something
pure and innocent that is Pure Evil and
these guys are marketing towards them on
purpose well said think about that yeah
you're right the tone was so casual
which this discussion was going on right
I'm looking at him going he has no clue
me meanwhile they'll they'll spark an
outrage against Matt wal for saying well
people used to get married much younger
for example women who were 17 years old
at one point in time would have been
married would have been mothers that's
historically accurate right we're
talking about the fact that people who
have been sexually developed who likely
within the same age bracket meaning if a
girl was 16 the boy was likely close to
16 they would be getting married by the
way you could also go to war to be clear
yeah outrage at that same people go yeah
but you know but everyone has their
fetishes everyone has their fetishes
right they like they like destroying
lives through taking the Purity and
innocence of people who have not even
hit puberty R yet and he just skims past
it and by the way to provide more
context because context is king and you
can by uh go to I think it's sound
investigations.com and see more content
from them and also on X as well they're
on X as well but I believe if you go
there they have they have actual
documents like petitions that you can
sign you can take an active role and
support them and please do we've been
working hand inand with them and I'm I'm
I'm very grateful that we're able to do
that in your support here is the context
of him uh I guess sort of providing more
information as it relates to the term
whales that you just heard I feel like a
someone drawn to
children would be have kind of more of
an insatable desperate appetite wouldn't
they be more likely to pay for something
yeah yeah I feel like that might draw
you can turn them into whales purchasing
a lot so whale just means you spend a
lot of money so like there's like it's
it comes from the idea of like small
fish doesn't spend a lot of money catch
a bigger fish dolphin spend a little and
whales spend a lot of money there's
another one what's her
name this is the one where we shot a
scene and she was supposed to be in a uh
like a playhouse for her daughter but
the way it's set up she looked like
it
um going to get
arrested I have had conversations where
I mean even in the industry we just be
like oh you know we're just we're all
going to disappear this is bad we're
going to get you know banned but like
there's no way that's
possible well you call that one it's
called The Prestige for
exactly also to give you an
update it was uh September 29th I
believe after uh our last expose in
sound investigations that there are 26
Attorneys General they signed a letter
uh to officially inquire about the
loopholes that were uncovered and the
letter by the way reads as you are aware
various federal and state laws forbid
the creation and distribution of child
sexual abuse material we are concerned
that Alo and its subsidiary PornHub and
possibly other subsidiaries may be
proliferating the production and
disseminate dissemination of the the
abbreviation they use is s sorry csam
for child sexual abuse material if
you're reading that um through the
loophole identified by your employee
well now you have employee number two so
this is where we can see if this is if
this is just a dog and pony show or if
they're going to do something they saw
what Ardon Young And Sound
investigations and M Club undercover did
last time they issued a threat now
you've got more and of course this will
be handed over to the people uh with
whom this would be relevant uh October
26th through the 27th I believe is when
our next guest Ardon young will brief
Congress on her findings and uh that
brings us I believe we have her on the
line from sound investigations here to
return is Arden
young Arden can you see me hear me thank
you for being with us yes thanks so much
for having me back absolutely and I know
Ginger Snap is very excited as well uh
let me ask you this this this is a new
update that we didn't know about uh last
evening uh did this happen this morning
or yesterday night can you tell us about
the legal threat that you received over
your
investigation yes we received a legal
threat from Alo pornhub's parent company
last night um they've asked us to
preserve all of our records about the
investigation and they've requested that
we remove all of the content we've
posted so far okay and uh let me guess
you're probably not
gonna no good for you we're gon to keep
going yeah I mean you can preserve the
records but um you know hopefully they
preserve their records that can be
investigated as it relates to child
pornography right we'll absolutely
preserve the records but we will not
stop what we're posting and let me ask
you this because people talk about
common ground a lot these days and again
people can go to um go to sound
investigations.com I highly recommend
they support you but people talk about
common ground you would think that
everybody every single person Nick and I
just discussed The Fringe left the DNC
every single person in the United States
of America aside from pedophiles
themselves would be on board with
exposing you know sexual abuse of minors
in any capacity has that been the case
or have you received other threats and
letters of Mal content with your
investigative findings um I don't think
I've gotten any outright threats other
than this letter I received a scary
phone call where there was like a
intimidating voice telling me like hi
are you ardan young I was like uh yeah
that's that's a that's Meant To Be A
Veiled Threat yeah it's like kind of
intimidating um I received some you know
comments from people who obviously work
in the adult entertainment industry who
aren't happy with these exposes but
other than that this letter is a first
legal threat but you've received some
some feedback from people who weren't
happy about it is is is my point oh
absolutely absolutely and why were they
was it just people who worked in the
pornography industry or were there
people who saw the investigations who
just who disagree with your your premise
because to me that's it's crazy if we
can't link arms and sing Kumbaya over
protecting children it can't be
done yeah mostly what I've seen is
people who work in the adult
entertainment industry or um are heavy
Watchers of PornHub saying you know I've
never seen anyone under underage on
PornHub or um you're trying to violate
free speech by you know talking about
this and that is definitely not what I'm
trying to do I am trying to end the
profiting off of sexual exploitation on
this huge platform right yeah we
discussed that last time too context is
King we said if consensual adults are
engaging in por you it may not be good
for you porn we've done several segments
on that but that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about you
know exploiting like you said uh sex
trafficking even if it's not outright
child pornography elud catering to it in
any capacity there's nothing healthy
there's nothing productive in that let
me ask you this as well because we just
talked about the letter that was by
those Attorneys General um have there
been any other officials legislative
officials or people in the government uh
government buildings I guess are
hallowed halls I use that term loosely
uh who've shown any interest uh
regarding your investigation in pursuing
something we've gotten interest from a
couple of senators we're in the early
stages of meeting with them and also
meeting with their human trafficking
task force teams but nothing absolutely
set in stone as of now but we're still
hoping for that okay good sorry if I'm
doing this I the CB just there there's
Menthol on this and I have a cut on my
hand and I rubbed it so don't know this
I apologize Ardon I think I think Gerald
had a question I actually do so Ardon I
just this is more of a statement but do
me a favor and when you talk with these
guys really press them I hope that some
of these people aren't using you to
sound like they're tough on this kind of
thing actually won't follow through
we've had a lot of dealings with
senators and and congressmen on section
230 and some other things where they
talk really tough and they'll be like
yeah we're actually we're going to go
get them and uh and then they don't do
anything and so make sure that when you
are talking to them and and maybe this
is the question part but just make sure
when you're talking to them that you
make that case like we want something
done we don't want a clip for your
campaign we don't want like a good media
piece but have they said to you maybe
that that they feel like they can get
something done in any of the
conversations that you've had or has it
been more General so far it's been
General no one's made that promise um we
do feel very hopeful that there are
several legislators and Attorneys
General who are serious about taking
further action upon our next releases
okay well maybe we can get a list of
some of the people that you speak to and
we can help hold their feet to the fire
yeah a little bit saying hey we know you
have this information it's uh what are
you going to do with it are you just
going to write a letter and and then
that's it and maybe just fit it into a
news cycle and then go or or what but we
definitely want to make sure that there
are results from this cuz you're you're
putting yourself on the line doing this
and drawing the IR of a gigantic company
like we talked about that the number one
company and everybody else kind of comes
to them they kind of have a monopoly on
the market we don't want it to be for
not yeah by the way careful though
because fire feed is another fetish yes
that's
true yeah I really appreciate that thank
you yeah absolutely this is one thing
you know it's they'll give you the
they'll give you the song and dance they
oh you know on Capitol Hill you have to
learn how to work with the other side
who's the other side of child sex
trafficking there should be no side at
all this should be one of those this you
should just be able to write in your
like yep yep yeah put them behind bars
we have people who are behind bars for
showing up January 6 not even not even
uh breaching the capital for years some
of them for 12 years to be clear nothing
is happening here I mean this is this at
least by the way people comment below
we'll take your chats this at least has
to be worse than what they did on
January 6 as far as the people who
showed up to March nothing yeah that's
how you know that there's a little bit
of
a I hate to be that guy who just says Ah
all on the same team but this is one of
those issues that you would think we can
all be on the same team uh together uh
let me ask you this it's sound
investigations.com we'll continue on mug
Club AR young what is the main takeaway
that you want people out there to know
regarding these investigations and and
what they can do to help support because
this is a big
deal yeah absolutely um we you can go to
sound investigations.com donate to
donate so we can keep going uh you can
follow me at ardore Yore on Twitter and
Instagram I'll be posting all the
updates there uh following and sharing
really helps offset the algorithm
because we are facing some censorship
and um just stay tuned for more videos
we have multiple more videos coming soon
featuring more employees yeah and that's
important to note too because especially
when dealing with Vice right you don't
really need to Market vice vice will do
well people will consume pornography in
copious amounts the censorship applies
to people who are trying to expose right
the underbelly of of that Vice and they
say well hold on a second this is now
this is getting on mainstream platforms
you know we don't want pornography
there's not there's pornography all over
Twitter all over these platforms it's
the same problem that we have often with
the church they go there's evil in the
world well show don't tell yeah don't
commit a crime but show don't tell show
The Bad actors let's call them out by
name and do something about it but
that's what often gets throttled yeah
and you know somebody right now who said
so social team right now make sure that
Elon Musk sees this like put this to at
Elon Musk because he has said he wants
to do a lot about kind of eradicating
this not only from the the platform X
but also in General child pornography it
seems like it's near and dear to his
heart he should be pushing this he
should be out there right now pushing
like these stories and investigations to
expose this stuff so make sure that he
sees it we can get in touch with whoever
we know you guys know exactly who I'm
talking about who has a pretty good line
to Elon right now get in touch with them
make sure that they get this in front of
him so that we can have an impact so
that this kind of stuff stops if people
are serious about it this is the way to
do it well he should yeah he should care
has like 42 kids he's a South African
man who lived in a shoe yeah all right
big shoe I'm going to continue uh Ardon
with you here on M Club if you're
watching on YouTube right now head over
to rumble if you're watching on Rumble
you can click this button right there uh
to join Mud Club and support by the way
not only to continue watching the show
none of these investigations partnering
with these people none of this takes
place without your support thank you
very much Rumble we will continue with
Aron Young YouTube piss
off
[Applause]
[Music]
what